Makes
about 7 years,
at 1 velodrome,
then the confederal left,
to the left of the sun in the state,
was in full boiling,
was in the assault on the skies
and we and we on that occasion,
at that velodrome,
we asked him 1 location and told him,
if in the Spanish state there is ever 1 occasion
history in which it can be democratized,
the pro-independence left will be there.
However,
if you realize that this is not possible.
or is only possible from stateless nations
and from the processes
to build stateless nations,
join these processes from the greatest of angles,
we want to tell the people who vote
to that confederal left today
that here in the Basque Country
and in this case in these 3 territories,
there is only 1 left that adds up
and there is only 1 left that can and it is called euskalerría
Pictured